[Music]
e.t the extraterrestrial was the highest
grossing film of 1982. let's
back when a movie ticket cost you an
average of two dollars 94 cents
and today moviegoers nationwide can
bring their wallets back in time to the
80s for national cinema day
over 30 000 screens and 3 000 theaters
across the united states will be
offering all show times all tickets all
formats for just three dollars jackie
brennaman president of the cinema
foundation says this is a thank you to
the film fanatics who helped welcome
back the theater experience with a
record-breaking summer our box office in
july of this year was 1.04 billion and
in 2019 it was 1.06 billion so the
numbers have been really good
we saw the release of movies such as dr
strange in the multiverse of madness
[Music]
jurassic world dominion do you remember
how we used to get the raptors in the
truck yeah
no
and top gun maverick two
one
which now stands as the sixth highest
grossing film in domestic box office
history
i'm assuming you know the book inside
and out damn right yeah i'm straight guy
and is raked in just over 1.3 billion
dollars worldwide so what is your enemy
we had
two years where people really couldn't
go out but when movie theaters opened
right back up we saw people coming out
in record numbers so there's something
different about experiencing
a movie with your community
in a dark room that just isn't
replicated anywhere else
while summer releases have given a
glimmer of hope for the theater
experience there is a long road ahead as
the industry continues to face covet
barriers
theaters are working with 30 percent
less wide release movies to keep their
operations running
cineworld which owns regal cinemas cited
this supply issue in its plans to file
for chapter 11 bankruptcy when the
movies are there so are the audiences
but we do still have supply chain issues
that will take some time still but as
long as we continue to show that
audiences are coming back to all types
of movies in such strong numbers then
there'll be continued investment in this
space
and that's a challenge people are to go
see top gun maverick in a theater but
maybe not they're because it's a good
movie it's a great it's seeing in this
thing it got us it got us the
screenwriter and author we profiled last
week said that movies have been dying
for a hundred years you know there's
always challenges right covid was
especially bad but if you but there's
something different about showing up in
a theater it is with your family it's
true as much as i love streaming and
staying in my pjs there is something
about being in a movie theater and
having that sound just coming at you and
being around everyone it's a communal
experience and nothing like
movie theater popcorn and hearing and
hearing danger zone
oh
into
the danger zone there it is